why does Hunter Hunter take so many
hiatuses when's the story going to end
what's up with gyro what's up with the
Dark Continent why are there so many
succession War bodyguards will gone get
nen back and when am I man on the
internet going to get all of the things
it is that I want Togashi has the answer
to all of your questions and more in
this apology letter because I know it's
very easy to get irritated at hiatuses
it's also very easy to call Togashi lazy
and too obsessed with video games to
work and it's even easier to just say
it's entirely due to health issues but
the truth is a bit more complicated
uncomfortable and a bit damning on the
manga industry as a whole so to set
things up we need to travel back to 1994
which was the final year of Hunter
Hunter's predecessor U haer we were in
the final Arc the three King Saga I
guess we're in the final Saga the three
kings Arc one or the other and the setup
is that there is going to be a massive
war in the Demon World between the three
demonic Kings which is really
interesting because what it turned into
was an optimized speedrun of youu Haka
show it had everything we'd come to to
expect of the series which was other
worldly Intrigue training and inevitably
a tournament well I say it had
everything it had everything except
enough chapters to tell the story there
was
6,272 entrance in this tournament and
said tournament began nine chapters
before yuu Haka show ended so the ending
of yuu Haka show was abrupt and whilst a
lot of fans do retrospectively defend it
Togashi not only knew that people were
disappointed but he himself was
disappointed and so this apology letter
was published in the final volume of U
haaker if I'm honest I'm feeling a great
relief and pleasure at the thought that
I finally been able to finish youu
haaker it's not that I've lost all
emotional attachment to the work but I
feel that my stress levels had greatly
surpassed my will to work the six months
leading up to the concluding chapter
felt awfully long to me to tell the
truth it had already been decided that U
Hawker show was going to end in December
1993 or rather this was a decision that
I had forced on the editorial staff
there were many reasons for this all in
all about 50 big and small ones but in
Broad Strokes these were the major
reasons one my body two thoughts I had
about what it means to draw manga and
three a desire to do things other than
work point three is out of the question
for a professional manga writer
basically I wanted to indulge in my
hobbies rest and sleep as much as I
could most of my 50 reasons fall into
this category and this is something that
I want to linger on for a second because
the truth of the manga industry is
pretty brutal even in the best case
scenario and then in the middle and
worst case scenario maro's Life as a
professional mangaka can be a living
hell in a tragic twist this is often why
mangaka have such fantastic imaginations
because drawing their stories is an
escape from their reality or a way to
live vicariously through their
characters just think about the concept
of a hunter license or hunters in
general Hunters are people with absolute
freedom to go and do whatever they like
their very profession is a dream system
and you add n on top of that and the
inbuilt system of the world gives your
imagination absolute freedom I'm an
absolute sucker his systems and you can
find find so much more system content
through the sponsor of this video web
novel a system story is essentially
where a character is transported or
reborn in a different world except they
have a super special power which allows
them to get stronger which you might
think sounds very Monsters and magic but
there's actually quite a bit of variety
and I've recently been reading the
hilarious n receives a dating Sim system
which is about an otaku named SEI haruta
who is reincarnated with a special
dating system or DS for short what I
love about this is that the system gives
SI a breakdown of all of his own
personal that and he starts out as you
honestly a pretty bottom of the bar
loser but throughout the novel he's able
to take these small victories small
victories that add up like say in
chapter 3 when he's talking to a girl
and look it doesn't go well but it also
doesn't go terribly which results in the
generation of a lovely little Charisma
point which goes on to completely
transform his life in a way that I
personally Envy let's put it this way in
the beginning SII is sort of like miliky
zalic just without all of the cool
assassination abilities and then we get
to watch him evolve into a fully-fledged
Sil AIC Chad and to read this and more
all you need to do is download the web
novel app through my link in the
description and search for the word
system and then a whole ton of great
works will pop up and you can also read
comics on the app as well I also wanted
to say a huge thanks to web novel for
sponsoring this channel which all goes
towards funding our wonderful Channel
artists and editors but it's also a
great app with great stories and it's so
incredibly easy to use so give web novel
a go but for now it's back to you me
Hunters a people with absolute freedom
to go and do whatever they like the
complete opposite of togashi's
profession as makaka but he continues
0.1 was caused by 3 not being fulfilled
for too long from When U Haka show began
serialization up until the start of the
Dark Tournament I had half a day off
every week in which I caught up on sleep
other than that all I had time for were
occasional naps and I'd indulge in my
hobbies by sleeping less for a while I
quite enjoyed this but my HP as they say
in RPGs was gradually but surely falling
and around the time that I wrote a 31
page oneshot and simultaneously had to
do color pages my heart began to hurt
every time I went without sleep and then
it began to hurt more and more often
this was when I seriously started to
think about the pace of production for
manga I thought I probably won't be able
to keep regular hours but if I sleep as
much as I want to when I want to how
much would I be able to produce I tried
it out I immediately began to fall
behind on my schedule but I tried to get
some sleep every night around this time
my feelings about writing manga as a
profession began to change I don't want
to die from overwork if I die I want it
to be when I'm having fun or when I'm
drawing manga for fun so something that
not a lot of people consider about being
a mangaka is that it can often be like
being sentenced to a prison of your own
choosing the success of your series and
the potential boundless wealth is
relevant to illustrate the most
successful mangaka of all time is at
your Oda and he has an estimated net
worth of just over2 200 million Us doll
U which is is a lot of money but it
doesn't change anything in the end etra
odor still spends 7 days a week working
in his office however odor is a rare
case where drawing manga is what gives
him the utmost happiness in fact he
feels the most free when drawing his
story yoshihiro tagashi is very
different in fact most humans are very
different I believe anyone who draws has
a desire to attract people with their
art but this is an ambition that I had
suppressed for a long time this is
because back when I just had my debut my
editor at the time had shown me a manga
Page by Hagi wadak kazushi bastard I
felt that if I were honest with myself
my aunt would never be able to compete
with something like this but I was never
able to throw away my ideal of being
able to draw manga without the help of
other people a few times during the Run
of you Haka show I finished my
manuscripts all by myself and these
instances were when my stress levels
were at their highest I don't know if
anyone will understand but when I was
stressed because I wasn't satisfied with
my manga the only way for me to relieve
this stress was to draw all my manga by
myself so this this is a very revealing
section because one of the most common
questions surrounding Hunter Hunter
production is why Togashi doesn't hire
someone to do the out for him while he
handles the story that is something that
I would personally love to see in fact
I'd be okay if Hunter Hunter left the
manga medium entirely and turned into a
novel but that's because I have an
addict likee craving for this story
these characters and this world I want
more of it in any form that I can get
but that doesn't work for Togashi and
it's a bit of a sad story really Togashi
deemed that he would never be able to
compete with the truly top tius of the
manga world not in terms of Aesthetics
anyway and as much as art is almost
entirely subjective I do think it takes
some pretty incredible self- awareness
to understand your own strengths and
weaknesses and being realistic even at
his Peak togashi's art was never the
strongest element of any of his works
but what's both heartbreaking and a bit
inspiring is that Togashi found
satisfaction in his art regardless just
VI the fact that it was his however what
that did is lead to a cycle of high
stress and the only way for Togashi to
deal with that stress was to draw
everything on his own but then as he
kept pushing himself eventually he
became not physically able to do that
leading to higher stress due to missing
deadlines and then the higher the stress
the stronger the desire to keep all of
the drawing to himself and it goes
around and around like that which is why
Hunter Hunter is where it is Togashi
still generally insists on drawing
everything himself he does have
assistance but he doesn't like to use
them as a result those chapters ended up
horrible both the characters and the
backgrounds were messy The one- Shot Two
Shots karasu versus Kurama yusuke versus
Sensi the scene where yusuke meets ryzen
I drew most of those alone the latter
two were finished in half a day before
my deadline as a reader guessed and
criticized in a letter this might mean I
fail as a professional but I was
satisfied I'd already started to think
that no matter what anyone says no
matter how messy the finished pages are
I just wanted to draw this by myself and
I had no reason not to go through with
it so in a way I do think that Togashi
almost invites criticism through
statements like this where he
essentially acknowledges that he failed
as a professional because it was his job
to perform a task at a certain standard
and he fell below that standard for the
sake of his well as he says selfishness
and personally I don't don't know if
selfishness is the right word I think it
has a very negative connotation but I
don't always think that being selfish is
bad in fact sometimes it's absolutely
the right thing to do when it comes to
Art though it's very difficult to draw
that line because it is a product that
consumers consume but also it's a
personal expression which again is very
much akin to being a hunter you have a
professional duty to further the
progress of the world and yet personal
expression is your first and foremost
responsibility much like n abilities as
well a personal expression applied to a
professional context but when it comes
to drawing manga there's this
uncomfortable mixture of creativity
always conflicting with responsibility
and from the perspective of the consumer
slth audience it can feel quite cutting
for an artist to make what they want how
they want it and most importantly in the
case of Hunter Hunter when they want it
in many ways it can feel like a betrayal
because you're not engaging with a
standard product or service most
products and service don't come with an
emotional attachment but being a reader
of a story with characters is
emotionally investing it saddens me to
say this but I had explored every
possible direction for the u- hawk show
characters that I could in the context
of a professional publication all I
could do at this point was start
deconstructing the characters or go on
repeating the same story lines over and
over until the readers got bored my
attempts to deconstruct the characters
were of course turned down by jump and I
didn't have the strength physically and
mentally to keep doing the same thing
over and over and I believe that Togashi
had a similar problem with Hunter Hunter
except in this case his ideas were not
turned down by jumper gone for example
was a difficult character to write in
fact in 2012 tagashi did an interview
where he stated that he deliberately
made gone a simple character so that the
support characters and antagonists were
given an opportunity to stand out and
shine but the flip side of that is that
eventually he ran out of creative thread
with gone himself so when the Chimera an
talk to get around that tagashi did what
he wanted to do with yakush show and
deconstructed his main character and I
also think that's why he was much more
okay with outright discarding gone as
his main protagonist most gaka would
never ever do that but Togashi was fine
with it because Hunter hunt was designed
with The Supporting Cast in mind from
the very beginning he ended up
deconstructing the entire Hunter
Association as well the Chimera an talk
was the first real sign that the hunter
Association weren't quite the benevolent
good guys that we were led to believe
dagashi injected a lot of Association
politics into this Arc and all of that
would obviously carry over all the way
to the current Arc and as wanky as it
sounds in a way tagashi deconstructed
the idea of humanity as a whole one of
the themes I love most about the Chimera
anti is following the progression of
humans becoming monsters and monsters
becoming incredibly empathetic and
sympathetic figures the gone example is
obvious but another one is netro versus
maram Neto is determined to deal with
maram violently whereas maram just wants
to talk and work things out with words
something you might also find
interesting is that in that same 2012
interview Tashi said that he often
writes alternate endings where the
villains win which I think explains a
lot of Hunter Hunter because we do often
end up somewhere in between where yes
the heroes win but at what cost so I
went ahead and did what IID always
wanted to do if I ever managed to have a
long serialization and jump I will end
it on my own terms I knew that jump
dropped a manga after 10 weeks if the
reader surveys proved it to be unpopular
and I knew this when I started working
for them this system proved encouraging
for me and I learned a lot by being
aware of Rita's reactions but I ended up
wanting to draw manga for myself without
thinking of anyone's reactions but I
don't believe that anything I came up
with on this premise would live up to
jump standards so I won't try in
conclusion I ended y Haka show because
of my own selfishness I'm sorry and yeah
I think that this is one of the most
depressing ways that any series could
conclude with the author just admitting
that it failed even if it didn't
necessarily from the perspective of the
reader it sad to know that the author
felt that way however there's a series
of very important lessons here that went
into the creation of hunter hunter in
retrospect I think the way that Togashi
ended U haaker three King Saga very much
informed how he wrote hunter hunter from
this experience Tashi learned that if he
wasn't feeling a certain story he did
have leverage as an author and he wasn't
bound to continuing it the thing I
really appreciate about Hunter Hunter is
that Togashi always gives 110% and it's
because it's a series that allows him to
draw whatever he desires at any given
moment sometimes that can be an
anticlimax for certain parts of the
story from a reader perspective but it's
a great strength of Hunter Hunter as a
whole and I would much rather this than
Togashi feeling forced to go down a
certain path and creating a more shallow
passionless manga and that's why he's
still making Hunter Hunter to this day
realistically he had an out after the
election Arc that could have been
goodbye to everything but unlike Yu Haka
show Togashi wasn't burnt out on hunter
hunter in fact he felt like he was just
getting started there was so much more
he wanted to do and explore because he
got to do and explore those things on
his own terms so now even in the face of
debilitating health conditions he still
wants to pursue it so even though the
hiatuses are annoying and realistically
hunt a hun may never end I still think
we've ended up with the best possible
out come given the conditions I would
much rather that Togashi continues to
draw a manga that he's passionate about
than feel the need to abandon it like
you haker because I love y Haka show I
have huge Nostalgia for it but if that
final Arc was the cost for creating
Hunter Hunter then so be it